[MUSIC PLAYING]
JORGE CUETO: Joining today
we have Pejman Nozad and Mar
Hershenson, two of the
most respected venture
capitalists in Silicon Valley.
In 2013, they teamed
up to create Pejman-Mar
and together invested in
over 30 startups including
Jordache, Garden Health,
Branch, and Gusto.
Just last year, they
announced their second round
of funding of $75 million
and rebranded to Pear.
On the who we are
section of Pear's website
are the following
words, "We understand
what it means to build
something from nothing.
That journey defines
each of our life stories.
We are immigrants, having
come to America penniless
but with big ideas.
We've been
entrepreneurs determined
to build great companies.
We know now that
success emerges only
for those who have endured
setbacks and overcome hurdles.
We've learned from
our failures and we
know what it takes to succeed.
There are no short cuts
when it comes to building
something extraordinary.
All of this finds
expression in our work."
That quote speaks
to what I think
makes Pear stand out among
venture capital firms
and it reflects the
unique personal background
that Pejman and Mar experience.
I'm very excited that both of
you are here with us today.
And maybe we can get
started by having
you share a little bit about
your background, where you grew
up, your career pathways,
and how you got into venture
capital and you can see how
your experience is reflected
in Pear's missions statement.
MAR HERSHENSON: Awesome.
Pejman, you should start.
PEJMAN NOZAD: Ladies first.
MAR HERSHENSON: Yeah.
OK.
I think Pejman
has a great story,
but I'll go with mine first.
I'm originally from
Barcelona, Spain and I
apologize for my cold.
I came to the US in 95 to
do a masters at Stanford
and I ended up getting a PhD
in electrical engineering.
This was 1999 and I was
ready to go to academia.
I had already lined
up a professor job
and at the last minute in
the crazy time of 1999,
I decided to reject that
offer and go do a start-up.
And that was my first start-up.
My PhD was in circuit design,
in analog chip design,
so it was fairly technical.
And I also did convex
optimization, large scale
optimization, so I had kind of
a dual background for somebody
in chips.
My first company
actually didn't work out,
but it was a great learning
ground for everything
that came afterwards.
And after that, I did two
companies that did work out.
So that was great.
Throughout my
journey, I met Pejman.
Pejman was an investor
in my second company.
And I remember going
to pitch to Pejman
and saying after my
first company had failed
and wondering who would give
me money, I said to Pejman,
I'm working on this, I've
learned what customers want,
I'm building this
software platform
using convex optimization
for designing chips.
And Pejman said, I have no
idea what you're talking about,
but I really like you so
I want to give you money
and I will have my friends talk
to you and if they like you,
we'll just put a round together.
And this was in 2004 and a
lot has changed since 2004.
In 2004, there was I think
maybe Tech Crunch had started,
but there was no
angel list, there
was no sense of angel
investing as a sport.
It was really a
few people and you
would have to raise by
going to their big houses.
Nobody was in a
coffee shop coding.
It was very, very different.
But Pejman was there doing
this from a very early point
in this seed movement
that we have right now.
So anyway, that's how
he got to know Pejman.
And he approached me
in 2010 with this idea
of doing a house where we
could work with founders
and help them build companies.
And it took almost four
years for me to pull the plug
and say, great,
let's go do this.
But that's how I got started
into venture capital.
PEJMAN NOZAD: Well,
thank you very much.
It's funny, I look at myself--
I don't have a
tech background, I
don't have an
investment background,
I'm a venture capitalist.
So that tells you a little
bit more about my background.
So I came 24 years
ago from Iran here.
I didn't speak any
word of English
and I didn't want
to come to America.
My brother just
pushed me to come here
and I ended up
going to San Carlos
because my uncle lived there.
I had $700, I lost all
the money because I
was calling a girl in Iran
that I really did love.
And I thought, if I don't
call her, I lose her.
So at that time, it
was like $4 per minute
because of the payphone.
So there was no Google for
none of these things today.
So my first job was
washing cars in American
and I ended up getting
a job at the yogurt shop
in Redwood City.
And I slept in an attic
above the yogurt shop
because I want to save money,
go marry the girl that I love.
And one of these nights
I was studying English,
I saw an ad that Medallion Rug
Gallery in downtown Palo Alto
is hiring salespeople.
So I ended up being a
salesperson at that rug gallery
and I became very good
at selling carpets.
And Persian carpets are
very, very expensive
so you don't sell
them at the gallery.
You take them to people's homes.
So in one year,
I sold $8 million
worth of carpet, which
is really unheard of.
But that tells the scope of
the sales and the relationships
we had with our customers.
But in late '90s, I figured
out all of my customers
are CEOs, venture capitalists,
founders of big companies.
And I was really amazed
by the amount of value
they're creating-- not only
nice homes and nice cars
and the ability to buy cars, but
just really building companies
based on knowledge.
And I thought, I want
to be one of them.
And I thought maybe this
is the opportunity for me.
I'm having a job and the
most important streak
maybe in the most
important time of my life.
And I started to
educate myself and I
learned about the ecosystem.
And think about it, this
is the '90s, late '90s.
There was no TechCrunch,
no YC, no blogging.
So the way I did
it, I started to put
a lot of events and
networking events at our place
and the deal first
started to kick in
and they started to invest.
I convinced the owner
of the rug gallery
to start to invest with me.
I didn't have money so
we started it and we made
horrible mistakes.
But I became very, very
lucky nine months into it
to meet Mar's husband
and Andy Rubin.
This was dangerous.
So Andy came one
day to buy carpets
and I was like really
in awe of this guy
and how he thought
about the future.
And then I said, I'm
angel investing and nobody
was giving them money.
So somehow, I became the first
investor and Andy and Matt
and Joe Britt.
And as you know, Andy
went on and built Android.
I'm actually the only person
in the world who gives Android
a term sheet but we didn't
agree on terms with Andy.
So you can be a good investor
but miss big opportunities.
So fast forward,
I ended up being
the first investor in
DropBox, Lending Club, Danger,
and many others.
And in around 2011-12, after
like 11, 12 years doing this,
I felt that companies are
raising a million dollars
but nobody's helping founders.
And I thought given my
background and network,
it's a huge opportunity to build
an institution to help founders
on ground zero.
And I wanted to
partner with somebody
who built companies, have
a deep tech background
and have the same
philosophy in life.
So I reached out to Mar
and I tried to convince her
for a few years.
We built this partnership,
we're kind of yin and yang.
I'm a college dropout,
she's a Stanford PhD.
I invested in 120 start-ups
before starting the fund,
Mar invested in only one.
But very complementary skills
and the same philosophy
in life, helping people and
really be good, give first
before you get.
And I think it
remains to be seen,
but Pear is now perhaps in the
center of the ecosystem here
in the Valley to just help
founders in really early stages
of the idea.
We have done so many
different [INAUDIBLE]
that we can talk about it.
And it's amazing to be here.
I remember my partners that
own Medallion Rug Gallery,
they own 165 University Avenue,
the lucky building Google
started there.
So I saw Google
when there were 120
versus today I don't know
how many thousand people.
So it's pretty amazing to
be part of this community.
We are really
honored and humbled.
JORGE CUETO: Pejman,
you mentioned
you worked at the
rug shop and then
you sort of used that
opportunity to transition
into doing VC by working
with your clients.
I think in Silicon
Valley, a lot of the times
there's a divide
between tech employees
who are tech workers
and everyone else.
So maybe you wouldn't
have necessarily
CEOs speaking and forming
genuine relationships
with people working
at a coffee shop
or serving tables
at a restaurant
or working in sales at a store.
So how were you able to bridge
that divide that exists?
PEJMAN NOZAD: I think I'm
good at making friends.
So once you become
friends with these people,
they listen to you.
So I wasn't going into
people's home selling carpets
and saying, hey, I'm investing,
let's do it together.
It was just building
the relationships
and I paid a lot of
attention to build
that real concrete
relationship with my customers,
who a few of them are
advisers to our fund now
and then a few of them
invested through our fund
so they became LP in our fund.
So it's very important
to build this very
authentic relationship
with whoever you work with.
So that was the genesis of my
relationship with clients who
became co-investors with me.
MAR HERSHENSON: He also
threw great parties.
PEJMAN NOZAD: Yes.
Everyone loves Persian food,
so whenever [INAUDIBLE] people
come.
JORGE CUETO: So throwing
great parties is the secret.
PEJMAN NOZAD: And inviting
their spouses so then
everybody will come.
JORGE CUETO: And
Mar, you mentioned
that you did a start-up that
initially didn't do well.
One of the questions
that comes up
when I talk about
start-ups with my friends,
a lot of them being
people of color and women,
is that they're concerned
that, especially
for first-time founders, there
is some bias from the VC world.
And I was wondering if you
experienced any of that
during your first start-up
and to what extent.
PEJMAN NOZAD: Yeah.
It was a very different time.
I think when I
left school, which
was the year 2000, the standard
way of doing a company,
whether you were a female
or not didn't really matter.
There was a tech
person and the standard
was we'll bring a CEO to run the
company and you will be the CTO
and that's the way companies
were run at the time.
And it has changed a lot.
Right now that's
not the philosophy.
People understand that
in good companies,
the founder stays with
the company all the way
and they're the CEO and they're
the one driving the company.
And that's what
Pejman and I believe.
I think we invest in
a lot of companies
where the founders are
either just out of school,
so definitely
first-time founders,
or maybe they're a few
years out of school
and they've had a couple of
jobs but it's their first take.
And that's what I think
we're really good at, which
is taking people that are
amazing and then teaching them
how to do your sales
pitch, how to fundraise.
It's not rocket science.
I think smart people can learn
it with the right support,
and that's our role, right?
So anyway, that's us.
I didn't encounter any sort of
issues, or I didn't feel them--
let me say that--
when I was fundraising or not.
It probably was more
in the workplace,
but not necessarily when I
was in the role of a founder.
JORGE CUETO: And I know you
worked at Stanford teaching
in addition to doing your PhD.
Did that experience
in academia, do
you think that helped you
with doing VC work now?
MAR HERSHENSON:
Surprisingly, yes.
Actually, I used to
teach circuit design
so it's very techie.
But a lot of what we do
is teaching in some way,
it's transferring knowledge.
Sometimes it's our
knowledge, sometimes
it's transferring knowledge of
other people to our founders.
So it's similar to what you
do when you are either guiding
somebody in a research
project or teaching them maybe
what's a transistor
for the first time.
There's a lot of
coaching that we do
and I did the same at
Stanford for many, many years.
So yes.
PEJMAN NOZAD: And I
want to talk about that.
So I mean, giving
credit to Mar and being
a lecturer and a
founder and having
a deep technical expertise
really helped for us
to really understand
opportunities
exist and really help founders.
One of our portfolio
companies is
a company called the One
Concern, which just closed
a massive $20 million
Series A. And Mar really
found them as a poster
session at Stanford.
They were pitching
their PhD thesis
and Mar saw an opportunity
that the groundbreaking
technology they have,
they can convert it
to a commercial company.
The didn't believe it.
They came to our office
and then fast forward now,
they're becoming really a
category defining company.
JORGE CUETO: And you guys
have done a lot of work
at Stanford, especially
with the Garage Program,
trying to get students to make
start-ups during the summer
and see if they can go even
further beyond the summer
work they do.
Did you decide that you
wanted to work with students
before starting that
program, or was the success
that you saw in
that program sort
of the driver for the
outreach that you do now?
MAR HERSHENSON: I'll
let Pejman talk.
PEJMAN NOZAD: I think there are
a few backgrounds in history.
So when I started investing in
Andy, I needed a few million
to start.
Today, basically you
don't need money to start.
As long as there's
a laptop, there's
a Starbucks, and AWS and
Google Drive and you don't die,
you can start a company.
And then there's so
much capital out there.
So there's lot of noise.
If you're a seed
investor like us,
how do you look at this
landscape of so many founders,
how do you pick the winners?
So luckily, Mar and
I started the fund
because of our background
with a very good deal flow.
But we thought in
order to increase
the quality of our
deal flow, it's
great to go inside communities
that are already filtered.
And Stanford was the obvious
choice because Mar was there
and then I had funded
a few companies.
And the first thing we wanted to
build the community over that.
And we thought it
would be great--
actually, Mar and I
thought the Garage Program,
we didn't have
any business plan.
We thought if you have
exceptional students
under one roof, something
good will happen.
MAR HERSHENSON: Maybe
explain about the garage.
PEJMAN NOZAD: Yeah.
Go ahead.
MAR HERSHENSON: No.
You go ahead.
PEJMAN NOZAD: So
Garage is a program
and every year we select up
to 20 students from Stanford.
It could be freshman all the way
to graduate or post-doctorate.
And basically,
these are typically
people in computer science
and engineering departments.
You don't need to have
an idea as long as you
want to be an entrepreneur.
So we select these 20
students for nine months
while academic year.
We give you space,
mentorship, and we really
help you find problems
you're passionate to solve
and help you build the product.
No expectation to
build the company,
no expectation the fundraise.
But it naturally happens.
So this is the fourth
year we are doing it
and we don't take any
equity in these companies.
We don't invest, we give
them a lot of resources.
They come to our office
once every two weeks
to check in with our
team and their mentors.
And already, six
companies came out of it.
One of them is a
portfolio company,
one was sold to Palantir.
Mar actually negotiated
the terms with Palantir.
We make $0, but those
two founders came back
and they're our founders
of our portfolio companies.
And because of that, I think
this community is growing.
And the philosophy you
give before you get,
we're kind of under the
skin of Stanford now
and we see things
before anybody else.
JORGE CUETO: As part of
your mission statement
that's on Pear's website,
you also mention--
PEJMAN NOZAD: We actually
wanted to recruit him,
but he didn't come.
JORGE CUETO: I had a lot
on my plate at the time.
In Pear's mission
statement, you also
mention that you're
looking for founders
that have unusual backgrounds.
Can you speak a
little bit to why
you decide to focus on
that aspect of founders
and maybe some
examples of what you
mean by unusual backgrounds?
MAR HERSHENSON: Yeah.
I think venture is
really interesting,
because especially for engineers
I think it's very interesting.
And the first time
I went into venture,
I said, oh, I'll just look at
all the variables about what
makes a company successful.
So I spent a bunch of
time collecting data
on actually semiconductor
companies over a decade.
And I would record I think I had
maybe 40 variables per company
and then I did some
simple regression
and I tried a few models.
Anyways, you're like
great, I have a model
and now I can predict what's
the next winner, right?
And it's almost the opposite.
We are a business of
exceptions, truly of exceptions.
And the really big winners, they
are just almost unpredictable,
right?
And it's almost
interesting, but I'll
tell you that the movie
about Facebook came out
and for a while
then, people thought,
oh, I must just fund
dropouts from MIT or Stanford
and we are guaranteed
to hit a success, right?
And now people are kind
of coming back out of that
and saying, no, maybe we should
fund people in their 30s,
when they're more successful.
So anyways, my bottom line
is that there is no formula.
I think everybody is different.
And we really like people
that are almost like unusual
and they've not gone
in a straight path.
So for example, we
just hired somebody
who was a chef for some time.
One of our founders
who runs a big company
called Memebox, an
e-commerce company,
it's very large in Asia, he
was in Afghanistan for a while
and he was an
engineer but decided
he truly wanted
to go into fashion
and went to Parsons School
and worked for Tom Ford.
So it's somebody that
was not something
that you would predict easily.
So anyway,
everybody's different.
This company that
Pejman was mentioning,
One Concern, which
basically they're
using artificial
intelligence to predict
in case of an
earthquake or a flood
where the big damage is so
you can send the emergency
responders very easily and
you can do prevention, right?
So this guy is from Kashmir.
He lived all his life
in this little village.
He suffered
earthquakes, floods, he
spent literally like five
days on the roof of his home.
And he knew that he wanted
to actually do something
to avoid being in the
same situation again.
So again, somebody with
a special background
that you want to
fund and contribute.
And I don't know if you
have something to add.
PEJMAN NOZAD: I think
on the broader spectrum,
if you look at the venture
capital community there
are a lot of people who claim
to be venture capitalists,
but there are more
capitalists, I think,
than venture capitalists.
And the reason is I mean,
especially when you come--
and actually, I met
another person yesterday.
I said, how do you
look at companies?
They said, when there is
no product risk and then
no market risk.
And I thought, wow.
So how can you be a venture
capitalist to do these things?
And in our business
you live for the moment
that somebody walks out
door and surprises you
and you break all the rules.
No terms is important.
Everything you earn
doesn't fit there,
and you really want to part
with that particular person.
And if you look at the
biggest company ever created,
the founders were
in that category.
JORGE CUETO: So
there's probably people
here in this room that
may be interested in doing
a start-up at some point or
maybe people watching online.
And you went a
little bit into this
with talking about
finding people
who are special and unusual, but
in terms of the type of company
or how a company
approaches the market,
do you have anything
that you look
for in the companies and
start-ups that you're funding?
MAR HERSHENSON: Maybe
let me say something else
about the founders.
Because it's not only like, hey,
you have an unusual background,
we pick you.
It's not just like that.
I think the founders
that we work
with-- at the very
beginning, just imagine
you are in our position.
There's people that come
in, they have nothing.
There might be a prototype, but
there's really nothing, right?
And they come in
and they're like,
we want money to
build our business
and we think it's
going to be great.
So we're just judging that
founder or founders, right?
And one of the characteristics
that I think is very important
is these people are
so mission-driven,
they're obsessed with
what they're doing.
It's like they can't sleep
at night because they
have to go to this company.
And I think when you are
obsessed and completely
mission-driven, there's
a lot of other things
that fall from it,
right, like your focus
and you're spending all your
time doing this and so on that
really matter.
But this obsession is
really, really important.
And I'll go back
to your question
about I think the market.
Sometimes there is no market
when we invest in companies.
We just don't even know.
You're creating a new market.
So for us, it's hard to look at
even a financial model or unit
economics or
margins or anything.
We just have to believe that
you could get there, right?
But we like people that
almost like are action-driven.
So they have a plan, so it's
not randomly things happen.
They're like, hey,
I'm going to try this,
almost like a math mind.
I'm trying to have
some sort of hypotheses
and it might not work
and it might work,
but if not I'm going to try
this and so on and so on, right?
It's almost like this constant
learning loop that they have
and it's not just like
I'm doing a company
and let's see what
happens, basically.
Go ahead.
PEJMAN NOZAD: I want
to add a few things.
Mar and I mean, when
we look at the founders
we like to work with, there are
some common characteristics.
We like founders who are really
close to the problem they're
solving.
Typically, when people
come and they say,
we have 20 ideas narrow it down
to 10, and we picked this one.
It's kind of a red flag.
We like people who have
lived through that problem
or they have
academically background
or you have faced those
challenges here at Google.
You are building a product,
but you see a huge opportunity
to do something.
So we really want to see that.
We like the teams who
have history together--
either work at Google or
they rock climb every weekend
or they went to the
same high school.
And as Mar mentioned,
people who have a vision.
Many founders, they
think they have a vision,
but they're just having
a goal of raising
more money into two years.
So it's very different.
And we pay a lot of
attention to figure out
why you're doing this.
I think most of the
start-up doesn't
work why you want to go
through these things?
And it's a very important
question that we ask.
And so it's a combination of the
characteristics of the founders
we want to see in the teams
when we are working with them.
JORGE CUETO: There's
been a lot of talk
recently in the news about the
importance of company culture
and making sure that you
foster a good culture
from an early stage because,
otherwise in the long run
potentially you could
be facing problems.
So since you guys work
with early stage companies,
are there things
that you see that can
be done since the
beginning of a company
to help create that
good culture, to avoid
those problems?
PEJMAN NOZAD: I think
everybody talks about it,
nobody defines what
it is in the culture.
I mean, the scope of Google it
is, but a start-up, what is it?
Is it a ping-pong table
or is it free food?
And I think it's should be
defined by the founding team.
And I think culture could
be different in any set
of companies.
But it's a set of principles
that you believe in
and you stick to it.
And it could be very different.
And one of the companies
I broke like 10 years ago,
it was an amazing
CEO and the culture
was all about transparency.
And I remember every
Friday they had barbecue
and he put himself in
front of the company
and everybody can ask
any question from the CEO
or criticize him.
That's one way to do it.
The other way is people say that
it's all about our customers,
I think we should service them.
And so this is a set
of different principles
that you should create and
you should stick to it.
MAR HERSHENSON: But I
think the most important
is to spend the time doing it.
The second time
you have a company,
you realize that's really,
really, really important.
And when you have
these principals,
it almost applies
to everything--
how you recruit, how you
treat your customers, how you
run your meetings.
So it's super critical to
have that conversation.
And you can get
help, get coaches
to help exactly what that means.
Because if you've never
done it, maybe you just
don't know how to do it.
But critical.
JORGE CUETO: And do
you have any advice
for people who are in early
stage companies trying
to get funding, particularly
maybe if they come
from immigrant
backgrounds, if they're
people of color or women?
PEJMAN NOZAD: Talk to us first.
MAR HERSHENSON: Yes.
Yeah.
I think the great
thing about the Valley,
especially if you're here, is
that you can get a lot of help.
People are typically
very, very helpful.
So you're almost a
block away from anybody
that can help either
with your business plan
or is a good idea
or not or research.
You can get out there.
These days, there are so
many things for founders
and entrepreneurs and events.
I think Pejman and I could be
on every night and every day
meeting people.
So I think if you really
start from nothing,
I would say reach out
for help to your network.
JORGE CUETO: And I think
a lot of times people
are really hesitant
to reach out.
But I've been surprised
how responsive people are
to an email or even if you
tweet them they might reply
and then you start fostering
a relationship over time.
MAR HERSHENSON: I think
one of the things that's
so important for
founders to know
is that there's a
lot of rejection when
you do entrepreneurship, whether
it's raising money or getting
customers.
Sometimes people will
come and it's like,
I've sent 500 emails
through LinkedIn
and I got two responses
and they're devastated.
I'm like, well, you got
two, that's awesome, right?
And it's really hard
at the beginning
to get somebody
to listen to you.
But the good founders,
because they're obsessed,
they don't give up, right?
And they're like, OK, maybe
LinkedIn was not the right way,
I should do this other
thing or whatever.
It's the same when you start.
JORGE CUETO: Do you approach how
you look at first time founders
differently than how
you approach people
who have had several
start-ups potentially
or who have pivoted?
PEJMAN NOZAD: Our
approach is not different.
It's the same way, but
obviously at different stages
you need a different
type of help.
If you're a second or
third time founder,
maybe you need an
introduction from us
to [INAUDIBLE] of a public
company and they take it.
But if you're a
first time founder,
you need to put an operations
plan together with us.
So it all depends on the
maturity of the founder.
And we've worked with both.
If you look at our
portfolio companies,
we have a lot of
first time founders,
but we have founding teams
that are second or third time
they're starting a company.
JORGE CUETO: Another thing that
I really appreciate about Pear
as a firm is that you
place a lot of emphasis
on the immigrant experience.
And especially right now in
today's political climate,
I think that's really important
and it's also very courageous.
And I was wondering
if there's been
any impact from the current
political climate on your work
with Pear, if you've seen
maybe changes in the people who
are pitching to you or
any changes in the people
that ultimately get funded.
MAR HERSHENSON: I think the
impact is on our companies.
I think we have founders
that can't go home
and that's a big deal.
If you can't go home to see
your sister get married,
I think that's a
big deal, right?
So at a personal level, we
don't have a large Immigration
Department like maybe you
HR like Google does, right?
So we've got involved
on how to help them.
But
So we have stories
that have happened.
We haven't seen
necessarily a change
in that people that come pitch
to us because some of them
are either on an H1 or
they're just finishing school
so they're on an
OPT visa or whatnot.
But Pejman and I are experts
at writing all these letters
of recommendation
for our founders
and I think a lot of them
have been able to get them.
Anyway, it's not good news.
Pejman is very committed to this
cause and he can talk bout it.
PEJMAN NOZAD: I came 24 years
ago as an Iranian Muslim.
And my immigration status
after I came was unknown,
but America never judged me.
It gave me all the
opportunities to thrive
and I still feel
the same thing and I
hope the spirit of America stays
that way when I arrived here
24 years ago.
And I think if you look
at this room, even,
and what Google and
people are doing
in Silicon Valley it's just
a testament of that spirit.
JORGE CUETO: And I
think sometimes it
can be difficult to
bring up one's background
or maybe make
connections to things
like your immigrant background,
given the political climate.
How do you approach
deciding when
to speak up about
something or what to say
in response to certain issues?
How do you balance those things?
PEJMAN NOZAD: I always learned
to stand up for my rights
and whatever it is.
And I think America
is a great country
that your voice is heard if
you just raise your voice.
I'm not hesitant to
raise my voice when I
want to stand up for my rights.
JORGE CUETO: And
when you do that,
do you see support from
fellow people in the industry
or have there been instances--
PEJMAN NOZAD:
Yeah, very much so.
I think especially
in the Valley,
you get so much support
from the people here.
I mean, almost everybody's
immigrant two grandfathers
backward, three.
I've got always huge support.
And even though the political
climate is changed by Trump,
I just don't feel it in
Silicon Valley it's happening.
It's the same Silicon Valley
I know for the last 24 years.
But as Mar mentioned, its
just very difficult I think.
I'm from Iran and
Iran has a university,
I think [INAUDIBLE] here has
gone to it, Sharif University.
It has the highest
acceptance of PhD
at Stanford, that EE
department, like Mar is.
People are deciding
not to come here.
They go to Canada or
they go to England.
So I think in the
end, America is
losing a lot of amazing talent
from all over the world.
MAR HERSHENSON: Maybe
I should say something.
I think sometimes we do get
founders that come and say,
I have a visa issue.
And I think Pejman and I,
once we find somebody we want,
will do whatever we can
to help this person.
It's no show stopper
for us so we'll try
whatever we can to get them in.
JORGE CUETO: I know
both of you are really
focused on giving back
to the communities
that you identify
with, and I was just
wondering if you could
tell us a little bit
about the ways in
which you give back
and your experience
about why you do it
and what you get from it.
PEJMAN NOZAD: Yeah.
I think it was the
Garage Program that's
an example of how much time
and effort it takes from us.
And without any specific
request of owning any ownership
in these companies.
So that really
tells that we really
want to give back, at least
to that particular community.
Specifically, Mar-- even
though some of the companies
we don't want to invest,
she spends so much time.
There's a company that we liked
to Stanford GSB business school
founders.
They wanted to get to
YC and then Mar spent
the last two weeks coaching
them how to get to YC.
And they got to YC yesterday.
So I think that that tells you
that we're all about helping
founders at the core.
JORGE CUETO: And you
also don't necessarily
see someone joining
another firm as a negative.
MAR HERSHENSON: No.
No.
I mean, I think it's a big
world and companies last
for a long time.
So you never know, right?
And a founder, it's rare that
you stay in a company forever.
You have many companies
inside of you.
So at the end, we just
want people to do well.
That's how I see
the world, anyways.
One company is not going
to make or break us.
JORGE CUETO: Do you have any--
PEJMAN NOZAD: Unless
it was Google.
MAR HERSHENSON: Yeah, exactly.
JORGE CUETO: They'll just
buy out all the companies.
Do you have any
stories about companies
that you funded that
you particularly
saw great success in and
maybe the qualities reflected
in their success?
MAR HERSHENSON: Yeah.
Maybe I'll talk about the
first company we actually
did out of a fund, it's
called Branch Metric.
It's a deep linking platform.
And I met them when they
were students at school
and so they were students.
It was November they were
students for still a long time.
But the CEO presented
what they were
doing at the time,
which was a mobile app
to print pictures,
which is completely
different from a
deep linking up.
But I came and I rushed
to Pejman and I said,
Pejman, we have
to fund this guy.
I don't really know what
he's doing, but he's great
and I'm sure he's going
to figure it out, right.
So that's how we
got into Branch.
They basically pivoted twice
until they did what they did.
But why did I think
in that first meeting
that this guy would be a great
CEO and was not going to stop?
He is what I call
a data-driven CEO.
So everything he says almost
has a number and a reason why.
So it's not hand-wavy and
he has done his homework
and he kind of knows
where he's going.
That's why I was like, I
want to work for this guy
because I know that we
are going to go somewhere.
And if we don't get them, he'll
turn around and figure it out.
And that's basically
what he did.
I mean, it's pretty impressive.
The success of the company
was not an accident.
The company pivoted twice
into what they're doing
and it was all really literally
data-driven decisions.
They're not getting
enough customers,
oh maybe we should build
an SDK for printing.
Oh, how do we get people
to install and open it
in the right place?
And that's how they eventually
got into deep linking.
Anyway, so that's one story.
I have many.
Pejman?
PEJMAN NOZAD: I
think you mentioned
that if you were telling me,
Pejman, you're starting a fund
and you invest in a
Korean cosmetic product,
I would have said I would
never do it until you meet
the founder and CEO of Memebox.
So as Mar mentioned, he studies
computer science in Korea,
then decided to go to serve in
the Peace Corps in Afghanistan,
then decided to go
to work for Tom Ford
and figure out that
Korean cosmetic products,
people love it.
After France, it's the
second biggest market
in the world of Korean
cosmetics products.
Much cheaper, same quality.
And he wanted to build a brand
that serves the entire world.
And fast forward, this year
they're making a lot of money,
they might go public.
So his desire to build
something in a market that is so
saturated was just astonishing.
And the quality of the founder
who walks through the wall
to make things happen was just
really, really obvious in him.
MAR HERSHENSON: And may I
say one more founder story
because I think those are the
best stories, not really ours.
But we have a company
called Aurora Solar
and it's founded
by two immigrants.
One is actually from Kenya and
the other one is from Germany.
These guys met at Stanford.
But the guy from Kenya, he had
started a solar installation
company in his home country
and when he came here,
he tried to turn
it into a business.
they realized that the solar
installation was very manual
and that they could actually
automate it with software.
Today, they're the
number one software
use for any solar installation.
It's actually super
techy and impressive.
But anyways, this was in 2013.
And time flies, but in
2013 if you said solar,
people were like, oh, no,
we can't talk to you, right?
So they could not get
any money, they could not
get any place to live or
work out of, et cetera.
So this guy, Sam, the founder,
called us almost begging,
please let us stay
in your office
because we don't
have anywhere to go.
And that's how we met him.
But just the fact that he had
the courage to come and say,
I don't have anything and
nobody really cares but lend me
a hand, that was a big deal.
So again, it's the
sort of mentality
that I'm going to
work and I want
to bring solar energy to
Kenya and I want to solve it
and I'm working on this problem,
I'm not going to give up.
So anyways.
PEJMAN NOZAD: And
that's why they
were chosen the number
one software company
in the entire solar industry.
JORGE CUETO: You both
talked about the founders
being very passionate
about specific industries
or specific products.
Do you have anything,
any opinion,
with regard to people who maybe
aren't working on something
that they're passionate
about but they're doing it
because maybe their financial
circumstances require them
to work in that or maybe
they're trying to build up
the skills to then do something
that they're passionate about?
Do you think there's a certain
point in which doing that
for too long can be a
bad thing and at what
point do you make the decision
to actually do something
that you're passionate about?
MAR HERSHENSON: I mean, it
really depends on people.
But I do encourage
the students that
come out of school to go get
a job or learn something.
It's not my recommendation
to do a company right now,
right after school.
It has to be a very,
very special situation.
Because I think you
learn a lot by you're
not done right after school,
you're not completely done,
right?
You are learning for the first
five to 10 years of your career
just really learning.
So we pay so much attention
as to what college we go,
but I think the impact
on your careers,
the first job you have is much
more impactful than necessarily
what college you went to.
So I'm totally
supportive of that
and that's the advice I
give to most people, right.
I think at some
point in your life,
it gets really, really hard
to go to a start-up because
of the circumstance of life.
You're making a lot of
money, you have a family,
maybe you are the only person
in your family that's working.
So it's just harder, right?
Again, people are super
obsessed, they figure it out,
right?
I mean, humans are very capable.
But it's harder.
PEJMAN NOZAD: My same
philosophy as Mar has.
I mean, I think sometimes
you do a job that just pays
for the bill and the family
and you might not really
be passionate, but I
think you can balance it.
If you like art, you can
spend your weekend doing art.
If you like soccer like
me, you can play soccer.
So I think Google is really
good at this 80/20 things.
I don't know if it's
going around or not,
but I think you can
balance your life.
JORGE CUETO: Yeah.
We still have 20% projects.
PEJMAN NOZAD: Find your passion.
JORGE CUETO: What about
looking forward into the tech
industry as a whole?
Do you see any
specific areas that
have a potential for high
growth in the coming years?
PEJMAN NOZAD: I mean, I let
Mar talk about the platform she
thinks is the future, AI.
But I think we don't know.
I think our motto is, investors
don't create the future,
entrepreneurs do,
and we stick to it.
We think always entrepreneurs
see future before us.
And we don't want
to corner ourselves
in any particular sector.
And that's one of the reasons
if you look at our portfolio
companies, you have companies
all over the map and the reason
is we really believe in
the founders were solving
a real problem in a big market.
MAR HERSHENSON: Yeah.
It's really hard to
predict the future.
To be honest, it's really hard.
And I know we are surrounded
by great investors that have
thesis and so on and so on.
And sometimes they get
it right, sometimes
they don't get it right.
I'll tell you my story.
I was in the
semiconductor business
and semiconductors was a
great industry in the '90s
and then it almost died.
All the venture
firms in the Valley
were funding semiconductor
companies and now
nobody funds semiconductor
companies, right?
So I thought I would never
work in semiconductors again
and the last company we
did was in semiconductors.
So you just never know.
And again, it's all
based on the team.
They had a convincing
pitch of why
that was a good opportunity
and all the issues
that one would face
with semiconductors.
We just kind of like
forgot about them.
PEJMAN NOZAD: When we
started the fund in 2013,
I think everybody was
talking about block chain
and then six months after
it was IOT, then was drones,
and today it's AI.
I mean, one investor
told me that if you
sprinkle a little AI on
your deck, you get funded.
And information changes
happen pretty quickly.
MAR HERSHENSON: And we see it,
everybody's on AI something.
We're like do you have
an engineer or something?
No, but we'll hire them.
I'm like, OK.
So we get.
Founders get it, too.
They're smart.
JORGE CUETO: What about
VR and autonomous--
MAR HERSHENSON:
Also, also, also.
I also heard something last
week, which is interesting.
I think autonomous driving
is on its way down.
I'm like, it hasn't even
made it [INAUDIBLE].
JORGE CUETO: Cool.
So I think at this
point, we can open up
to questions from the audience.
AUDIENCE: What
percentage of women
were participants in
the Garage Program
since you've done
it for four years
and do you do anything to try
to recruit from that category?
MAR HERSHENSON: Yes.
OK.
I'll tell you, in the first
year we started Garage,
we did it with two people that
head the ACM Group at Stanford.
And the way we started
was, hey, why don't you
come up with a list of 20 people
that we could reach out to,
right?
So they came to us and
that 20 list was all guys.
I'm like, OK, guys, we need some
diversity in this group, right?
So we had to force them
to go find some women.
And I think we had in that
Garage group four women.
Two actually were of
color, which was great.
But it was clearly
not the majority
because we had about 15 to
20 people, give or take.
And the second year
we did call out
for people and the same
ratios to be honest, right?
We've tried really hard.
This year is actually
maybe the highest
that we have in terms of
ratio, but it's always
under 50% for sure.
I would say around 30%, 35%.
PEJMAN NOZAD: But we
do some initiatives.
Like for example, we do a lot
of Hackathon at our place.
The first Hackathon
was only for girls.
And the winner had dinner
with John [INAUDIBLE],
which is like kind
of life-changing.
And if you look at our
portfolio companies,
we have pretty amazing
female founders.
And we picked them because
they're the best at what they
do, not because they're women.
They're really exceptional
at what they do.
So we don't wake
up in the morning,
so next quarter we'll only fund
men and then the other quarter
women.
These women are just
really exceptional
and happen to be
the founder or CEO
and we're very lucky
to work with them.
MAR HERSHENSON: Yeah.
So mostly it's reachout
that we've done.
We did a reachout for she++,
which is a group at Stanford,
and it's a great group.
Anyways, we hosted some sort
of design thinking activity
for them.
Anyway, this was
maybe two years ago.
But out of that we met
our current engineer
in residence, who
happens to be a woman,
and she came from that
reachout program that we did.
So that was great.
AUDIENCE: So you
spoke about founders
who have lived the problem
or have experienced it
in some way.
As someone fresh
out of college, I'm
interested in solving
problems for enterprise
because I see that
the software there
is much worse than the stuff
that we have as consumers.
But obviously, I've
only ever worked
at very tech forward
companies like Google
where we build our own
solutions to all these problems.
What is some advice
you might have
for someone like me to either
go get that experience myself
with those problems
or find people?
PEJMAN NOZAD: I have some ideas.
So I think first of
all, you have to find--
I mean, when you say enterprise
is just such a big place,
I think you should figure
out where in enterprise you
want to focus and get
educated and go to places.
As Mar mentioned, there's so
much information online you
can find and there's so many
groups you can go and learn
from them, there are some
conferences you can go.
But narrow it down and exactly
what you mean by enterprise.
And just surround
yourself with the people
who have done it
before, ask questions.
MAR HERSHENSON: And
sometimes the best thing
is to actually try to
put something out, right?
And I mean, I want
to say so easy,
but it's relatively easy
to mock up some stuff
and run it by
people in industry.
I don't know if you
have any ideas in mind.
But that's what I encourage
people to do in the Garage.
When they don't know
what to work on,
we actually bring
speakers to tell them
what problems they have.
That's how Garage started.
So we would bring people
from media or people
from real estate or e-commerce
and they would be like,
these are the problems we have.
And students would actually say,
work because they would come up
with solutions.
Similar to you,
that's how it started.
They said, we can
code anything, we just
don't know what to code.
And so anyway, they're getting
the feedback from people.
And I encourage, like Pejman
said, you can do the same
but you almost want to
take it a step further.
This is when you
tell people, I'm
going to build this,
what do you think?
People are like, oh yeah, great.
Great.
And people say like, wait,
I have product market fit,
I'm going to go do it.
And truly, until
you tell somebody,
will you pay me for doing
this, Then if you have
to really product market fit.
And sometimes people just
need to see a little more
than an idea in words or some
sort of PowerPoint et cetera.
But anyway, just start.
That's my big advice.
That's the best way to finish.
JORGE CUETO: One
of the questions
that we got is what advice do
you have for someone at Google
who is interested in going
into venture capital?
MAR HERSHENSON:
Talk to Pear, right?
PEJMAN NOZAD: No, you're open.
Actually, we just hired a person
from Stanford Business School
that she's actually in food.
So she worked for Good
Eggs, she was a chef before.
And given her expertise
and background,
we are creating a call
for a start-up in food.
So if you're interested
in any particular way
of being a venture capitalist,
we'd love to talk to you.
And when you think venture
capital world from outside,
it looks like you sit down in a
meeting and you look at a pitch
and then you provide
some feedback.
It's just one part of
being a venture capitalist.
I think a good venture
capitalist should
have a really good deal flow.
I think if you don't
have a good deal flow,
you end up picking
the wrong founder.
So if you're coming
out of Google,
you have already a
great community here
that could be a good deal flow.
You have to be able
to pick winners.
It takes time.
But just find your
niche if you want
to be a venture
capitalist because it's
a saturated market.
But as always, the industry
looks for talented people.
MAR HERSHENSON: Yeah.
I want to say
something about that
because I think it's the
same advice I gave earlier
is the best way is to start.
And I think we live
in a world where
you don't have to wait and
get permission to get started,
right?
So let's assume I wanted to
get into venture capital now.
The first thing I
would do is start doing
some angel investing, right?
I think if you're working
at Google as an engineer,
I would guess you can use some
percentage of whatever you're
making every year
and devote it to do
some angel investing, right?
And just doing a
couple of investments
is going to teach you so much
about what it takes, right?
Like Pejman says,
it looks some way,
but once you get in it's
kind of dirty and messy
and it requires a lot
of time, et cetera.
The other thing that I think
the world has given us right
now is this amazing social media
and kind of digital access.
So there's a lot of people
in the last five to 10 years
that have built their own
brand just by I have a podcast
and they talk about something
or I have a newsletter on AI
or whatever.
Every day there's some
new vertical or pitch
that people do and they're
getting enough sourcing
that they build their own
deal flow to get going.
So anyways, again,
whoever answered
in Dory, that mysterious face,
I'm happy to chat with them.
AUDIENCE: Some of
the entrepreneurs
I respect the most have
either lost everything or been
on the verge of losing
everything more than one time
and they're so
determined that that's
OK they caution to the wind.
Is that something you
look for, that people
that if they didn't have any
path to funding from a group
like yours, that they
would just figure out a way
and be prepared
to put everything
at risk for their idea?
MAR HERSHENSON: Sorry,
can you repeat that?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So do you look for something
that is a proxy of this
willingness to-- that
you'd be willing to go--
MAR HERSHENSON: We do.
AUDIENCE: The
entrepreneurs that are
really good or they seem,
they have gone bankrupt
one or more times or
are on the verge of it
and is that something
that you look for?
MAR HERSHENSON: I mean,
it's not bankruptcy
that we're necessarily
looking for.
But yeah, I mean, we do
look for that person that
is like, I'm working on this.
Sometimes people come and it's
like I'm starting this company
but I'm working
here in the meantime
and you know
they've been working
and they could
afford quote unquote
to go do something full time
and really commit, right?
So it's definitely
a sign that doesn't
make us feel super comfy
about the founder, right?
But again, everybody's
different, right?
And some people-- it doesn't
mean because you have it
easy, you can't
be a good founder
and it doesn't mean
because you haven't hired,
you're automatically
a good founder, right?
It's a business of exceptions.
AUDIENCE: One of
the hardest things
I hear my friends
say about at VC
is that bad ideas look just like
the good ideas at first glance.
And when you become good, you
get thousands and thousands
of deals coming
across and you have
to be able to spot the ones that
look bad but are really, really
awesome.
What are your secrets
to doing that?
PEJMAN NOZAD: I think
it's kind of the pattern
recognition among the founders.
We typically want
to meet founders.
Last year we met
2,000 companies.
We met 2,000 companies.
Normally, we get about
10,000 leads and so on.
And because we do it so early,
we typically look at the idea
and we really want to
get to know the founder.
And in part of it is
just pattern recognition.
When you do it
for so many years,
you just understand
the character
of some of the founders.
But yes, I mean, like
in the case of Branch,
the first idea was
FitBit for dogs.
No, seriously.
And I think no one
wants to do that.
But it was about
the founding team
and the character
to build something
and their determination to
do it that attracted us.
MAR HERSHENSON:
It's really hard.
I think there a high error rate.
A venture looks very glamorous.
We're only known
for our successes,
not for our failures, right?
So we can invest in
companies that don't make it
and nobody knows
or nobody cares.
I think it was really
important for the founders.
We could miss 10 great companies
and it's nowhere to be seen,
right?
So I mean, we have our
own internal KPIs to see
how we're doing and so on.
But I think we're almost
lucky that we're not measured
externally on those misses.
But it's hard.
Truth, it's hard and
everybody misses, right?
And I think only hard work and
obsession gets you to be better
at the end of the day.
JORGE CUETO: Do you
have any notable misses
that you can talk about?
Yes, Yes, we do.
It's early in the fund
because we may have
missed more than I know of.
I think we missed Box, which
is a giant company now.
It's like Costco online.
And I think, again, if we
had stuck by our principles,
sometimes it's like
missing our principles.
It's really hard to say,
great founders, something
doesn't make sense but it's OK.
And at the time, it's like, wow,
are they competing with Amazon?
Who wants to
compete with Amazon?
And it was a little later stage,
but we missed that company,
for example.
AUDIENCE: So what kind of advice
do you give to the founders,
whether they're looking
for new founders
or they're looking to bring
the first three or four
people on the team, what kind of
characteristics and what advice
do you give them as
they expand bringing
new people into the team?
MAR HERSHENSON: That's
a good question.
And I think--
OK, in general,
so I think there's
two types of recruiting.
One is like your founding team
and then obviously, a lot of
plys later the first 10 people,
the first 100, et cetera.
But if you are building
that founding team,
the most important advice
is to take your time
and actually be super
focused at doing it.
It takes time, right?
It doesn't just happen by
itself that all of a sudden,
you find your founder
and it's a perfect thing.
It's because you are out
there and you're trying
to find this person, right?
And you can't just hire the
first person that comes along
or bring or get together
with the first person that
comes along.
Because its like
finding a wife, right?
You could marry your
first girlfriend,
but maybe it was a bad idea
if your first girlfriend
was like 14.
I don't know.
Its the same thing, right?
So you have to be super patient
at making the right choice.
The second thing is I think
its good to find people
that are complementary,
especially
if you are starting from zero.
If you want to pull
out a company together,
you maybe need
somebody that has--
an engineer, a front end
engineer, and a data scientist
maybe, and some person
that's more in operations
or sales or something, right?
Sometimes it's one person that
can do three things, right?
Because you have
a founder that is
excellent at
speaking to customers
and they've built
everything and so on
and they can just pull it out.
But sometimes you
need two people,
sometimes you need
three people, right?
And I think for me, I
think it's important--
I see it in companies when
the critical components
of the company are in
the DNA of that company
from very, very early on,
you have a higher chance
of success.
Not always the case.
But a good example is if you're
building a consumer brand,
some companies will say, oh,
we have this great product
and we'll hire a branding
agency later, right?
But if you're a
consumer company,
it's good to have consumer
DNA early in the company.
For example, you should
go find that person.
I call it the
minimum viable team.
So the minimum viable product.
PEJMAN NOZAD: I want to
add that a lot of people
can build product, not many
people can build companies.
So if you're looking
for a co-founder,
look for those people who
have, as Mar mentioned,
complementary skills.
But it can help you
build companies.
If you're looking for a VP of
engineering as a co-founder,
it's not enough to just
be a great engineer
as you built the product.
You just need to be
able to attract talent.
So just spend a lot of time.
And I learned that spending
time socially tells a lot
about that particular person.
So get them out there.
Go for a walk or
go see a ball game.
Just get to know them
and just be patient.
And then making sure you
share the same vision.
The most difficult thing as an
early stage investor is when
founders cannot get along.
You always can raise money, you
can always change the product
and pivot, but when you
don't have the same vision
and you can't look eye
to eye, we can't fix it.
AUDIENCE: So a
question for you all,
when should someone go to YC?
Only because there's about
so much mindshare here
versus taking seed VC from
a VC firm like yourself?
So that's the first question.
And the second one is, how
do you differentiate yourself
among other VCs?
Because for all of us here who
live and breathe technology,
we hear of so many
VCs all the time.
a16z has a very strong
marketing machine.
So how do you sort of
benchmark yourself against them
to sort of stand out?
PEJMAN NOZAD: I
think today there
are pretty amazing accelerators
out there, including YC,
and they have done a really
good job in the last five to 10
years to really help
founders from ground zero
to get to the next stage.
It all depends on your need and
what you can accomplish there.
There are other resources
that you can use to not
go through an accelerator.
But again, I think it's case
by case. it's very different.
Yes, the venture capital
community is just very crowded.
But again, if you are
looking for people
who can help you
the first 24 months
and help you build
the foundation
of a long-lasting
company, you need
to look for venture capitalists
who have that experience.
I think that their firm is
set up to serve you in that
and they take the
risk and they are
able to navigate the
challenges that you have.
There are other
VCs that you only
go to them when you
have product market fit,
you have a customer,
and you can scale
and you want to build
an engineering team.
That's a different skill set.
We don't have that skill set.
The DNA of our fund is helping
founders at ground zero,
especially in the
first 24 months.
So that's where
we've set up but.
And Sequoyah might be
completely different.
You can go to them
when you have customers
and they can help you to
become a massive company.
MAR HERSHENSON: Maybe
I want to say something
that I think is really
important for founders.
There are multiple ways to
build a big company, right?
There is no one single place
you need to go to be successful.
At the end, the companies
work not because of us
but because of the founders.
And we're really like
support and we try very,
very hard to support them.
But at the end, it's really the
founder that makes or breaks
the company, not us.
I hope not us, anyway.
AUDIENCE: What sort
of characterizes
when you see someone who has
been at Google for a while,
sort of like what are the
characteristics of in your mind
picture when you see
someone like that?
And the maybe particularly
for product management?
Another way of asking it
is, what kinds of things
should we make sure we
learn while we're here?
MAR HERSHENSON: Good question.
Well, first of all, maybe
I will say something
before Pejman says
something smarter.
We love the PM role as
a CEO for our company.
We think it's just amazing.
Because when you're a PM,
you're like a mini CEO, right?
When you're a CEO, you just
have more responsibility
because there's just more--
I mean, you're on the
edge all the time.
But it's a great experience
and I think the more broad
it is, right, like all
the way from customer
to talking to the
engineer, the better--
the more exposure,
the more projects,
et cetera, and seeing things
from end to end, right?
Because it's different taking
a project from zero to 80%
and from 80% to 100%
and getting it out there
and following up what
happens when you put it out
and customers are
using it, et cetera.
I don't know exactly how the
PM thing is organized here
at Google, I apologize,
but I know every company
is slightly different.
But just all the way
and I think broad,
that would be my advice to you.
PEJMAN NOZAD: And it
all depends if you're
planning to start a company.
I think it depends on you have
to build your network here,
it's an amazing place
to build a network.
I met this CEO who is
building a great company--
we actually missed being an
investor in that company--
and he was the PM
of a large company
and he telling me for
four years he was PM.
Every time he shipped a product,
he then went to a smaller team
and started from ground
zero because he knew
he wants to start a company.
So he was always uncomfortable
being in a big team.
So he always requested the CEO,
I managed to ship this product,
I just want to go start
again from ground zero.
Just give me more
tasks that I can do.
And speaking of that,
I have a request here.
As Mark mentioned, we
think PMs or companies
are the best founders we
have seen because they're
their own CEO and we are trying
to build a conference or a boot
camp maybe this year or
next year for PMs who
want to start a company or
have already started it.
So we'd love to hear from
you what type of topics
you want to be covered.
So you can email,
Pejman@pear.vc.
I'd love to hear
from you because we
think it's just a pretty
amazing place for us
to partner with the
future founders.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
reaching out and getting help
from people, and
that's always something
I've been nervous about.
When asking for
help from someone
like yourselves, who
are busy individuals,
do you have advice for
how to ask for help?
Should I go well it's a
well-formed, clearly scoped
30-second question or are
people like yourselves
interested in having
kind of open-ended, kind
of broader discussions as well?
PEJMAN NOZAD: I always
found the people
who reach out that are very,
very specific, I respond.
I always respond, but the
ones that are very specific,
I make time.
But the ones that say,
oh, can I have a coffee,
I want to run an idea by you,
it's just not that specific.
I don't know how I can help.
We're just so busy.
So just be very, very
specific and target the people
who can really help
you and they're even
passionate about the topic
you want to discuss with them.
MAR HERSHENSON: I think
I'd meet more people.
I'm like lower bar, I would say.
But I think for me when
people tell me their story,
again, like hey, I'm
at Google or I've
been working on
this for a long time
and I'm thinking
of doing this, do
you want to have a chat
with me, and if I have time
I definitely will do it.
But again, sell yourself.
If you don't have a company
to sell, sell yourself.
PEJMAN NOZAD: Yeah.
And actually, this goes back
to when you go fundraise,
I think sometimes you
tell your story is
as important as your
product and metrics.
And most of the founders
shy away to say that,
to tell their stories.
They actually push them.
They start the page
and say, where did you
grow up, how did you do it?
So we just want to
get to know them.
So when you go pitch, don't
be shy to tell your stories.
AUDIENCE: What was
the hardest part?
After you started VC, what
was your hardest thing
that took to get used to?
Where did the struggle, what
were some common pitfalls early
on?
You had mentioned like trying
to create a linear regression
with all these
parameters, trying
to optimize and try to bring in
some complex optimization here.
Other things that
you struggled with?
PEJMAN NOZAD: I think
today when you look at,
this is like three
and a half years fund,
we have over 60 companies
that we have invested.
So finding the time to help
these people while we still
serve the community, that's
a big challenge for us.
That's why we are
building a team.
As an angel investor, so before
that I was an angel investor.
When you are doing
an angel investment,
you just keep investing.
Just invest and every
new company you invest.
You're excited.
You go to the next one.
When you are
managing a fund, you
want to invest in
30, 40 companies,
so you have a discipline to
concentrate in portfolio.
That's a big difference.
Every company we invest today,
that means one less company
in the next three years.
But when you're
an angel investor,
you never think about that.
You just keep investing.
MAR HERSHENSON: I think for
me, the hardest thing was
imagine you've being an
operator all your life
and all of a sudden
you're an investor.
So I think for the
first year, we didn't
have that many companies.
When you start, you don't
have any companies, right?
So Pejman knows
this story, but I
remember one Sunday I was
there and I was writing code
for one of the companies.
I'm like, OK that's not right.
But there's a lot of inertia
in what we do as humans.
So I am no longer
are doing that.
So that was my
hardest adjustment,
knowing that I can do it.
My job is to teach
somebody how to do it.
I'll suggest how to do it,
they have to make the decisions
but I shouldn't do it.
AUDIENCE: Every
several years, there
are new big trends
in the industry.
So there are a
lot of things that
are very hot right now like
self-driving cars, VR, AR, AI,
et cetera.
So how do you
evaluate this field,
how do you think
about those trends
right now and then what
will be big things that
can change the world or change
the industry in the next five
or 10 years?
MAR HERSHENSON: You're right.
Every 10 years, there's
like this big change
that has happened in
the Valley, right?
And I like to tell the story
that in '76, it was the PC;
10 years later in '86,
it was maybe the router;
and 10 years later, in
'96, it was the internet;
10 years later, in
'06, it was the iPhone.
So people are like, what's
happened now in 2016?
It's already passed, right?
And I tell people, it's probably
an Nvidia GPU processor.
That's probably the next--
it's like an equivalent
of that router.
And a lot of things, the fact
that when I was doing my PhD,
I was doing convex optimization,
which is almost the anti-deep
learning way of
solving a problem.
And the deep learning
people at Stanford
couldn't even run a little
20-circuit amplifier,
they couldn't size it, right?
And fast forward 17 years,
you can do amazing things
with deep learning.
So these platforms
that take place
like the iPhone or
the internet, it's
not something that just
changes particular behavior.
It changes industry, it
changes the enterprise,
it changes media, it
changes the consumer.
It changes everything, right?
In the case of
that Nvidia GPU, I
think the same is
going to happen.
We're at the very,
very beginning
and a lot of technology
cycles, they're
like second order systems.
They overshoot and then
they go back, right?
So the internet everybody
was like, overpriced,
and then it kind of settles.
Same with mobile
apps, with everything.
So now we're in the cycle
where everybody's super
excited about AI or VR and AR.
Even VR and AR I
think it's even still
a little early in
the investment cycle.
But you have to do your
homework as an investor.
It's in our job, right?
When you say AI, not all AI was
created equal, I think, right?
For some cases, you absolutely
need to be 100% accurate;
for some cases, it's
OK if you're 80%
and you can build a
product around it.
Maybe we won't be 100% for
another five years and so on.
And those are the sort of little
things that we are evaluating.
But again, at the end,
we're thinking it all
goes back to the founder.
Is the founder aware
of where they are
and where he is and the
limitations of what they have?
And so on.
PEJMAN NOZAD: As a firm, Mar
and I, we are aware of trends
but we don't follow trends.
And if we think
when it's hot, it's
already too late to invest.
I think you want to
partner with founders
who see future before anybody
else and you partner with them.
And if you look at the best
companies ever created,
they were not in any hot space.
It's like the stock market.
When it's too hot,
it's too late to buy.
You want to make sure you
buy those stocks at the time
that not many people know.
And for us, it's
just really rather
than looking for what is
hot, we look for outliers,
for those founders who are
determined to build something
really massive in the market
that they believe exists
and we can help them.
MAR HERSHENSON:
And in the cycles,
it really is like
this overshoot.
The best companies almost
get funded four to five years
after the big change.
It's like even when
Google was founded,
it was not Yahoo, right?
A little later, Uber; a little
later, after the iPhone.
It's like radical change maybe
takes a little bit of time.
JORGE CUETO: All right.
Well, thank you.
We are out of time, but
it was really great.
MAR HERSHENSON:
Thank you, Jorge.
PEJMAN NOZAD: Thank you all.
Good questions.
[APPLAUSE]